we've heard about terraforming the Moon
and Mars as we attempt to colonize space
but what about Venus if we did manage to
terraform our neighbor one day it could
look like this could we live here one
day how different would it be from life
on Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if we terraformed Venus
believe it or not Earth and Venus are
very similar at times Venus is even
referred to as Earth's sister planet
they're both roughly the same diameter
have the same mass same gravity and are
both made out of the same material
a central iron core and a rocky mantle
unfortunately the comparisons end there
unlike Earth Venus is extremely hot has
an incredibly dense atmosphere and toxic
fumes on its surface what would we need
to do to make it habitable scientists
and astronomers have been theorizing how
to terraform venus for over half a
century the two biggest issues that need
to be solved are the atmosphere and the
temperature on Venus currently the
surface of Venus is a sweltering 462
degrees hot enough to melt lead
and the atmosphere made up mostly of
carbon dioxide is 93 times as heavy as
Earth's one proposed way of altering
Venus's atmosphere is to bomb with
hydrogen hydrogen bombs when reacting
with the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere would create graphite and
water this would fall down to the
planet's surface and cover 80 percent of
it with oceans mind you there wouldn't
be nearly as deep as Earth's oceans
Venus would only have ten percent the
amount of water that Earth has this
would take a lot of hydrogen the only
way we could get enough is if we were to
harvest the resource from Jupiter or
Saturn this approach would also require
iron aerosol a material that can be
mined from asteroids if all went
according to plan the dense carbon
dioxide atmosphere would be reduced to
being just three times as heavy as
Earth's
[Music]
that's manageable this would also help
clear the clouds of sulfuric acid that
hang over the planet okay
the atmosphere is clear now what about
the temperature one way to cool the
surface is with solar shades a series of
small spaceships or one large lens that
would divert the Rays of the Sun these
solar shades could be placed on the
surface of the planet or in the
atmosphere slowly working to cool down
the planet and reduce radiation another
issue that would need to be resolved
before we started living on Venus in
addition to solar shades NASA thinks
that we could build floating cities
above the clouds of Venus these would
work as a safe living space as we learn
and attempt to terraform the environment
to cool the planet even more and to
speed up the process cooling pipes could
be put on the surface of the planet
these pipes would take heat from the
surface and bring it up to colder parts
of the atmosphere now we have a suitable
atmosphere a proper temperature and
clean air but there's one other huge
issue that humans might have if they
move to Venus
they'd have extremely long days and
nights since Venus rotates once every
243 Earth days meaning a day on Venus is
5,800 hours long not to mention it's the
only planet in our solar system to
rotate clockwise meaning that it's
extremely slow sunrise would happen in
the West and sunsets would be in the
east we could create the illusion of a
24-hour day cycle by using massive
mirrors and having them rotate to
reflect the Sun if this managed to work
correctly Venus would feel just like
home with maybe a touch less gravity
after all this Venus would finally be
habitable sure the planet would rotate
differently and you'd get a different
view of the Sun but it could be another
place for humans to live scientists
theorize that it could be a backup
planet one day studying more about Venus
could teach us something about Earth
Venus suffers incredibly strong
greenhouse effects the cause of its
extreme temperatures and dense
atmosphere by learning more about
cooling this planet it may unlock the
secrets to cooling our own and maybe
make our home last even longer
but that sounds like a story for another
what if
[Music]